foreign
is now investigators learning more about
a plot to defraud Southern Nevada
casinos documents revealing that scheme
involves at least three different
properties eight news now investigator
David charns broke the news about the
first of these steps and David what do
you know well Brian Denise we're
learning documents that we obtained
revealing the man official says involved
in that theft of more than a million
dollars from Circa is believed to be
tied to at least two other similar
events at other casinos we're also
learning each of these cases involves a
person calling a cage employee from a
Mexican phone number first told you
about this that police arrested
32-year-old man accusing him as posing
as one of circa's owners tricking a
worker in stealing more than a million
dollars from the resort Eric Gutierrez
allegedly contacting the Casino cage
saying he needed money to get safety
devices for the fire department police
say an employee then met off site with
Gutierrez possibly another person
handing over nearly 1.2 million dollars
in several installments now documents we
obtained today revealing Gaming Control
Board investigators suspect Gutierrez is
involved in thefts at the Eureka Casino
in Mesquite and the Golden Nugget in
Laughlin in the Eureka case documents
say a person called the Casino cage
supervisor who then removed 250 thousand
dollars and drove from Mesquite to Las
Vegas to deliver that money to a person
who she believed was owed money for hand
sanitizer officials believed that person
who this person met with was Gutierrez
right now he faces just two theft
charges he did not want to talk to us
from jail and his lawyer did not return
a request for comment documents say
officials believe this whole plot may be
connected to someone in Mexico who then
wired money to European bank accounts
we've also learned in addition to the
Gaming Control Board in Metro the Secret
Service is involved in this I reached
out to both of the casinos named in
those new documents today I did not hear
back we'll stay on top of this I'm David
charns 8 News Now and there is a lot
more to this already complicated story
you can read more right now on our
website and inside our free app Dave